-My first guest tonight is a
talented and hardworking actor.
He stars in the show "See"
on Apple TV+.
Here is Jason Momoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man! Ahh!
Ah, I've missed ya.
I love you, buddy.
It's so good to see you!
-I love you! I love you, Jimmy.
I'm sorry I'm not there, bud.
-No, please.
Anything. I understand.
Next time -- Next time, I want
to see you in person, pal.
You look great.
That's exactly what you want
Jason Momoa to look like.
Am I wrong? You are a stud.
Look at you. Look at you, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it! I love the set.
I love the hair.
Would you ever
cut your hair short?
-Hell no.
-Yeah. Never, right?
No. Have you ever?
-I mean, I'm not a big fan of
haircuts or cutting anything.
My beard or -- I'm -- Yeah.
-Yeah, just grow it
all the way out.
-Well, you know,
most of the roles I play --
Like, "See,"
I've got to have long hair.
"Aquaman," I've got to
have long hair.
So until I need to play
that role, I'll wait.
-Yeah. Would your wife be cool
with you if you cut your hair?
-Probably not.
-I wanted to talk
to you about --
I know Justice League,
the Snyder cut,
the director's cut
came out during quarantine.
Four hours, by the way.
I loved it.
-I thought it was fantastic.
I was going to ask you.
What did you think of it?
-I mean, listen, I love Zack.
And that's kind of
what I signed up for,
whatever, eight years ago,
is to have his vision.
And, you know, the cool thing
about that four-hour piece
is that I didn't reshoot
anything.
Like, that was all there.
-Really?
-So it's interesting when people
come up to me and they're like,
"Oh, I really love this,
and it was so detailed,
and it explained so much."
I'm like, "Yeah,
that's what we went and shot."
I didn't have to redo anything.
So, you know, because
of the tragedy and, you know --
I'm happy we made one,
but I'm really happy
that we got to release his art,
and a lot of fans are happy.
-Yes.
-And the truth of it is,
I like the four hours.
And normally we watch shows
that are, you know --
It's just a four-part series.
So, I like the extended
and spending time
with the characters, so...
-Well, Aquaman
made another appearance
this year on Instagram.
Dwayne Johnson. Do you know
what I'm talking about?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, Dwayne asked you to
make a video for his daughter,
'cause his daughter loves you.
My kids love you, too.
My whole family loves you.
We're just big Jason Momoa fans.
But we have a clip of it.
Here's Jason Momoa's birthday
message to Dwayne's daughter.
-I'm sorry I couldn't be there.
But I love you.
And tell your papa
that I love him, too.
Happy third birthday.
-Yay!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's so cute. But I love that.
He asked her -- He's like,
"Who is cooler --
Daddy or Aquaman?"
And she didn't even think
for a second.
She goes, "Aquaman."
That's so funny.
Do you know Dwayne for a while?
-Yeah.
I met him, gosh,
almost 20 years ago.
We were in Hawaii when we met,
and we have
a very close friend, who --
You know, we kind of met through
that and stay in touch.
And we've tried to get together
and make a movie together.
It's just he's way busier
than I am,
and I'm pretty busy right now,
so one of these days...
-You have to make a movie
together. You have to.
-We will,
and it's really cool now,
because he's kind of
in my pocket.
So I can call him up
and be like, "Yo."
I got him.
-You owe me a favor." Yeah.
"I did the birthday message.
Now you've got to do a movie."
Exactly. Yeah.
Before we talk about "See,"
I wanted to quickly mention
another project you're doing.
You're involved
in the new "Dune."
That is going to be giant,
buddy.
-It is a masterpiece.
It is -- I've never been in
anything, like, on that scope.
Denis is a genius.
And I got to see it.
It was really cool 'cause
my kids were up here,
and so we got to
take them to it.
It's the first time
I got to see something like that
with my kids. It's a very
adult movie, but so beautiful.
-Yeah.
-The cast is massive.
-Yeah, oh, it's heavy hitters.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That comes out --
Come back for that, too.
That comes out on October 1st
in theaters and on HBO Max.
But now I want to talk
about "See"
because this is fantastic.
It's on Apple TV+ and
just renewed for season two.
But then I just heard today
it got renewed
for season three, as well.
So congrats, bud! Dude.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's huge news. It's huge news.
Because it's literally the --
It's probably the hardest
and greatest character
I've ever played
just in the sense of, you know,
the whole world is blind.
-Yeah.
-It's just very challenging.
And I love the cast.
I love the crew, the world.
And it's tough.
If I'm not fighting, I'm crying.
And just -- It's pushed me
on so many levels.
-Yeah, you're right.
But that's kind of --
That's kind of what I think
about you when I think of you
in general.
I mean, you're a big dude.
You're an actor.
I mean, you're a tough guy.
But, also, you're a family guy,
and you're one of the
nicest guys I've ever met.
And so I like
watching you do this.
Because you get to fight people
and, you know, crush people,
and then you also
get to love your kids.
And it's like -- Yeah.
-Yeah, it's a man trying
to keep his family together.
It's beautiful
and it's emotional,
and I love the journey,
so I'm really excited
to do another season
with everybody, and so --
Yeah.
-Here we go.
I want to show everyone a clip
of season two of "See."
Check it out.
-Good morning, Baba Voss.
♪♪
-It's been a long time, brother.
[ Crowd shouting ]
♪♪
-I swore I would never
return here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, buddy!
Jason Momoa, everybody!